it's um a little after 10 and so we'll
go ahead and um get started with the the
special hearing um Mr
Ripple is this a is this a public
hearing is this some um do we need the
to verify that the video is
on it isn't on just yet but it will be I
think they usually wait for you to open
it so it should be on actually I'm I've
really become much more a heart of
hearing so it's on now okay thank you so
much all right so um I would like to
refer to this as a special hearing just
to make everyone feel like they they're
not wasting their time I'm here today
this is um an educational session I
don't expect us to there's nothing for
us to vote on um so this is really uh an
opportunity for members of of the
division three to cross level what they
know about tanif tanif is a pretty
important program it's got a lot of
flexibility in it um I think uh we could
potentially uh think more about uh how
we would want to proactively use it um
in the next budget cycle for those of us
that uh come back to this um this um
committee uh I know that uh
representative walner has paid some
attention to tanif in the past and and
brought forward legislation in
hb2 that uh where we spent tanif money
and um and I felt a little embarrassed
by it because I didn't fully real
realize what flexibility we had with
that program and and what other
opportunities we might have had so this
is this is my attempt to have us get um
get ahead of the budget cycle a little
bit get a little bit smarter about this
important program and uh and I've
proposed an agenda I assume you've
received it Mr Herbert yes I have
received it thank you okay you have any
problems with it like anything that you
don't think we can cover today not at
all okay
fantastic um okay so with that I think
uh we're ready to get going you can just
freelance at this point very well so my
name is Karen heer I'm the director for
the division of economic stability in
DHHS I just would ask you because I I
don't know why my hearing is so off but
if you could really project into the Red
Dot okay I'll do my best thank you is
that better it is better okay so I just
wanted to say thank you for your
interest in the TANF program TANF does
stand for temporary assistance for needy
families uh and I appreciate the agenda
that you provided um my presentation
will take more or less 15 minutes uh and
I will address every item that is on
your
list uh so tanif was created by the
federal government in
1996 it is a fixed block grant for
states and the federal statute uh for
tanif provides that tanif grants must be
used in any manner reasonably calculated
to accomplish one or more of the
following four purposes if you leave
with nothing else today these are the
key uh pieces to tanif that uh pretty
much Drive uh Drive the Grant and and
that sounds like the four bullet points
that are on the second page that's
that's correct all right thank you so to
provide assistance to needy families so
that children may be cared for in their
own homes or in homes of relatives
that's the first purpose the second is
to end the dependence of needy parents
on government benefits by promoting job
preparation work and
marriage the third is to prevent and
reduce the incidence of outof wedlock
pregnancies and to establish annual
numerical goals for preventing and
reducing the incidents of these
pregnancies and the fourth purpose is to
encourage enourage the formation and
maintenance of two parent
families on slide three will you will
you take questions as we go make this a
little more conversational I'd be happy
to that's what you prefer okay so
bullets two three and four I think are
fascinating to me because uh as issues
of of government policy I'm I'm actually
not very familiar even after paying
attention for 20 30 years what
government has done to encourage
marriage um and to parent families so do
you have some examples of things that we
are actively doing in New Hampshire to
do any of two three or
four I'm going to talk a little bit
about that through the presentation and
specifically more focused on number two
um as well as three and that is in
collaboration with other programs in
DHHS such as child
support okay so on two if you could just
come back to the marriage part because I
I I I can see how government works to uh
promote job prep and work but uh it's
the it's that marriage encouragement
that just has me baffled it's more of a
prevention strategy um so that you could
prevent um the need for for Public
Assistance programs uh and I can't off
the top of my head point to a particular
initiative that has been specifically or
directly um targeting the prevention of
Public Assistance uh in terms of
marriage promotion but um indirectly I
think some of the programs do support
that so the next slide page
three states fund their tan of programs
with a combination of federal and state
funds there are two primary Parts the
first is the annual federal block grant
which for New Hampshire is $38
million the second primary part is the
annual state funded maintenance of
effort also referred to
ASE which for New Hampshire is $32
million so so help me with the math is
is that a total of um 60 million
altogether or or does the maintenance of
effort bring in money beyond the 38
[Music]
million no it's it's 60 million total Mr
White 70 yep 70 million oh God it's been
a long time it's math right so in
addition uh New Hampshire currently has
what is known as the tanif
balance currently that balance is at $69
million as of September 30th of
2023 this amount includes the current
Year's block grant of 38
million so of the 69 million um is it is
it non- lapsing or it is that's non-aps
so we just need to figure out what our
long-term strategy is for this I think
right all right and do you already have
one I am going to touch on some of the
future plans that we do have as well as
current
initiatives okay do any of the members
already think they have a long-term view
of where to go with this 69
million this is the beginning of the
year well it's been around though this
is this money has been
accumulating uh yes for yes the
bium Y
all right all right go ahead so the
federal tan funds are used by the state
to provide
assistance and the recipients are
subject to work participation
requirements as well as a 5-year time
limit on the federal assistance and the
state is subject to data reporting and
certain
prohibitions these restrictions do not
generally apply to other services and
benefits that are not referred to as
assistance states have broad discretion
to provide a wide range of benefits and
services and to set different
eligibility standards for the different
types of
benefits for statee funds whether the
state spends $1 doll of all the federal
dollars states still have to spend all
of the required maintenance of effort
dollars with respect to the tanif
balance many states have un unobligated
T of funds available giving them an
opportunity to invest in families with
significant barriers to employment to
provide add additional supports for
lowincome Working Families or design
pregnancy prevention and family
formation programs efforts must extend
to reach needy families including those
who face multiple barriers to success
and who face time limits for receiving
Public
Assistance States May transfer up to 30%
of their Tana funds for a fiscal year to
the child care and Development Fund also
known as
ccdf as well as the social services
block grant referred to as
ssbg with respect to certain
prohibitions we are prohibited from uh
providing uh assistance or using the
funds for certain teen parents convicted
felons individuals convicted of fraud
medical services and there is a 15% cap
on administrative
expenditures we are prohibited to use
this fund for other programs supplanting
or satisfying matching requirements or
things like buildings or
construction so so a question before we
leave that page um the um the second and
last bullet says the states May transfer
up to 30% of tanif is that
um the com the com combination of
federal ande or is that just federal or
is that just
the it's just Federal it's it's a 30% of
the federal correct so 30% of 69 million
to start the next budget 30% of 38
million yes good and
then do you know if
ccdf or ssbg
either of them carry an
explicit Mission or function or
objective to prevent out OFW
childbearing or to encourage two parent
families there is no there isn't a
current initiative uh that I'm aware of
for ssbg or for ccdf uh with the use of
tan of funds for either of those
programs so so if the legislature
thought those were important functions
transferring the money out wouldn't
necessarily be a good way to get the
resources no and it's important to note
that if you do transfer money to either
ccdf or
ssbg the the funding then takes the form
and characteristics of those particular
grants which have a whole host of other
requirements to each of them all right
thank
you does anyone have any questions at
this point go ahead represent
tki thank you thank you for taking my
question I'm just reflecting a little
bit on
the um prevention of out of wedlock
childbearing in terms of the fact that
it's um temporary assistance for needy
families
and how the funds can are they can it be
money directly
to families or women to prevent out OFW
like childbearing or can that money be
used to say agencies that have
educational programming and counseling
for
that thank you for the question it's an
excellent question I uh would have to
look into that particular detail a
little bit deeper I can tell you that we
would uh need to be able to take a look
at what kind of an initiative we would
um uh be considering to um to have for
that particular purpose um right now our
primary focus is on the assistance cash
assistance as well as uh the work um
work requirements and uh trying
to move people out of Public Assistance
by way of employment and supports for
employment can I ask a followup please
so what I guess I'm trying to understand
and I just use that as an example is
this money goes
directly to support an individual or a
family or cash assistance to a family
this money does not necessarily go to
agencies or partners that um provide the
social
assistance and resources that are
sometimes needed or is it a mix of both
it's it could be used for you know the
formation of a particular type of
service that may Target those particular
purposes okay so it okay I'm just trying
to wrap my brain around how this money
can be spent thank you y so it's been a
while since we've all gotten together
and uh I just want to remind everyone
that um I I think the style that this
committee has adopted is that once you
start to ask questions as long as you're
being consistent and and being
respectful of boundaries um you just
keep talking U let's have a conversation
and not you know not not go back and
forth on the formality of it let's just
talk okay okay um your turn to talk
again great thank you and I think a lot
of questions could very well be answered
in some of the uh points in the
presentation on slide
four uh within the statutory framework
State tan of programs provide a range of
benefits and services that can serve as
critical support to families who are
experiencing economic hardships
including the provision of cash cash
assistance if we as we mentioned
employment and training assistance and
other related services such as emergency
assistance as reflected in the state's
plan to avoid incurring penalties under
federal law a state must meet Moe
requirements each fiscal year that is
the expenditure of State funds in tanif
or a separate State program for certain
benefits and services
also was established in federal law each
state must expend funds that meet a tan
of purpose for eligible families in an
amount equal to or at least 80% of State
spending from fiscal year
1994 this required amount can fall to
75% if the state meets its tan of work
participation requirement for the fiscal
year work participation rates measure
the degree to which a state engages with
families to receive assistance that are
funded by tanif ore and work activities
specified under federal law a state
faces Financial penalty for a fiscal
year if it does not meet the work
overall work participation rate of
50% New Hampshire currently has a
61.7% work participation rate so we're
good
okay I'm sure the definition of a two
parent family is in the statute
somewhere um would it
include
um a couple male female couple
childbearing age um that does not have a
child but is doing foster
parenting I don't uh yeah actually I
think it I think it would
but I would have to follow up on that
would you please because one of the
challenges I think the state has is that
we don't have enough foster parents in
the
system and if there is some employment
Assistance or job training you know
maybe maybe we could figure out how to
get these programs to be a little
complimentary
yeah yeah and as I understand it so
differentiating between foster care or
kinship care so for kinship individuals
who are related or can certainly apply
for the tanif benefit um otherwise
specifically just foster parents who are
not related to the child would not
qualify for T of funding you're you're
probably right could you could you just
verify that in the next week or two or
I'd be happy to no
hurry um so so then it would go without
saying
that a couple wishing to have a child
would not be eligible until what point
until there's a confirmed pregnancy or
confirmed birth no birth and deprivation
of one or both parents segregation
deprivation say say the word again
deprivation oh deprivation poverty or
something deprivation of one or both
parents
okay
thanks yeah represent
wner thank you I just wondered if you
could maybe just really briefly touch on
emergency assistance
programs sure um I can provide certainly
the the state's policy on with the
criteria for emergency assistance if
that's what you would like
okay so on Slide Five you would ask for
a bit of the history both Federal and
for the State of New Hampshire oop
sorry what is the FY
94 level that we're based off
of uh the school year 9
UM do we have that for maintenance of
effort 32 oh yeah the 32 million for
maintenance of effort that's
the that was the baseline from FY 94 yes
thank
you so again on Slide Five uh a little
bit of the history I'm not going to go
through each of these but I have
provided really some of the key events
uh in history for the federal program uh
one that I would draw draw your
attention to really uh that is key is
the personal responsibility and work
opportunity reconciliation Act of
1996 otherwise known as pora you may
hear it pronounced by its acronym that
uh Act created the tanif program and
repealed a former program known as the
aid to families with dependent
children I don't want to interrupt you
but I'd like to understand this a more
clearly so back on
whatever slide you talked about you said
the maintenance of effort $32
million and down here you're talking
about it's being 30% of some number 1994
does that mean 1994 number is three and
a tenth or three and a third times as
much as $38 million that we're working
off of or is it 30% of $38
million yeah the 30% is what can be
transferred to the other programs that's
not what I'm asking about sorry so on
slide four under two avoid
penalties it references 75 to
80% of State spending in fiscal year
1994 so what I'm trying to understand is
what was State spending in fiscal year
1994 for
afdc that is the 32
million the that's what we spent in 1994
yes so
so if I may interject representative
Earth so we spent slightly more than
that but the $32 million that
maintenance of effort that was set in
law back in the90s that has never
changed so basically our maintenance of
effort the amount that we have to spend
every year to get the 38 million has not
changed at all and so the federally set
level of 78 75 to 80% so I I I would
need to just back into the number with a
calculator to understand what the
spending was in 1984 but but the the 32
million is the percentage of that so it
it would have been probably closer to 39
or 40
million okay yeah does that help it
helps if it's
true a follow yeah related I think I
seem to remember we're um we were
talking about why to put in a certain
amount into the budget for Tana from the
state when we had so much unspent and my
my um recollection was that if we didn't
put in that much the amount of federal
funds would decrease permanently that we
had to continue to do the 32 million a
year or we'd have a permanent reduction
in the amount of federal money being put
into this program and at least am I kind
of close yes yes so um I believe it was
during the Governor's phase some of the
money that we had set aside for tanif to
meet that maintenance of effort was
reduced and then during the house phase
some of those funds were added back into
this budget to make sure that we could
spend that $32 million because um as uh
Karen had indicated earlier 15% of this
can be spent on administrative costs so
some of this pays for positions but if
those positions are vacant then we can't
actually earn that that maintenance of
effort so to speak or if cash assistance
decreases you know um we can't earn that
maintenance of effort but yes that was
all part of that discussion and it's not
that it's permanently gone it's that we
have to pay a penalty and then the
subsequent year there'll also be a
reduction in the federal funds that are
coming forward so it's almost um this
isn't a technical term but it's almost
like a double whammy so to
speak yeah thanks that's that's kind of
what I remember yep that's precisely
correct thank you
let me grab my
coffee so on the history uh Slide the
federal history slide it's Slide Five um
the personal responsibility and work
opportunity reconciliation act referred
to commonly is Pera uh which had created
the tanif program uh which Pro so so
tanif does as I mentioned provide the uh
fixed block grant and for all states
that's about 16.5
billion to States and territories of
Interest the tanif annual funding has
never been adjusted for inflation in its
27-year history and is now worth almost
50% less than when the program was
created okay that that I'm sure that's a
great math stat um what I always want to
translate those kinds of statements to
is what is happening to the workload
measurements are are we are we seeing uh
a significant decline in the workload
that's being funded and is the decline
in the workload sufficient to where
we're causing real problems that we can
identify specifically I mean it's one
thing to say we're spending less than
half but it's another to say and the
impact of that in human terms is the
following are you able to articulate the
second part of that when you say
workload I assume you're meaning
workload and what the human impact is of
having probably reduced
workload so I I would have to you know
really conduct quite a bit of an
analysis on that for the last several
years but you know
okay um I think that would be difficult
to really pinpoint the cause for any
shift in workload because there are many
influencing factors for the tan of Grant
but also the
participation uh of uh or the
utilization rather of the the tan of
program you know we just have a simple
decision here you know when it comes our
turn we either provide x million or Y
million or Z million and really what we
ought to be doing is an analysis of of
what the state is getting for its return
on investment and that's got to be tied
somehow to workload and human impact I
think I can say that you know from the
top of my head I mean we've certainly
shifted the focus over the last decade
or more uh on the the the uh level of
um initiatives and programs that we have
strengthened over the years specifically
to get people uh the support that they
need to find not just find a job but to
be able to keep that job or basically
more focusing on upskilling people
towards career and career lack ladders
so there's a lot that we and I'm going
to talk about that in a few minutes but
there's a lot that we are shifting the
focus for uh with respect to the New
Hampshire employment program uh as we
see um you know a bit of an evolution or
changes in the environment if you
will representative wer a significant
number in my mind if if we're spending
by inflation only 50% of what we spent
those many years ago would be the size
of the populations from that that period
of time to the populations now and if
the population has decreased then we're
looking at a successful program so
that's what I'm really interested in
have the number of people we helped in
in 1990 four
1996 has that population decreased or
increased that that particular
population has decreased over the last
decade and I have a slide that I'm going
to show you at least the last three
years so you can see it's relatively
steady probably over the last five or
six years um but uh definitely decreased
over a longer term which I would see as
success in the
program on slide six you will see the uh
States history of TANF more or less at a
a glance I'm not going to go through all
of these but you will note again in
1996 the enactment of prora
um and uh some events uh that uh came
after that for New Hampshire I'm happy
to dive into any of them if you would
like otherwise I'll move to slide
seven you had asked about the misuse of
Tana of funds that may be known to us in
other states I will first preface that
by explaining that the federal
government does have an obligation to
set out in regulations CR IIA that it
will use in carrying out its authority
to enforce certain tanif
Provisions by assessing penalties in
cases where Tana of funds were spent for
unallowable
activities I can tell you that in 2020
charges were brought against six State
officials for misappropriation of tan of
funds New Hampshire is not one of them
in Mississippi there are eight criminal
defendants and 4 seven civil defendants
at the moment that the Miss Mississippi
Department of Human Services is suing in
an attempt to recoup $77 million in
stolen or misspent federal
funds in New Hampshire the state
legislature had P passed a law outlining
penalties to be applied if cash
assistance recipients were found to have
conducted electronic benefit
transactions or EBT at restricted Loc
locations and now attempts to use EBT
cards at certain business types is
blocked so are the close by ATMs uh to
these establishments this includes the
liquor store Casino or gaming in uh
establishments retail establishments
that provide adult oriented
entertainment smoke shops tattoo parlers
and marijuana
dispensaries regardless of this the EBT
administ rator in the state monitors the
transactions in cases where an
individual is sanctioned the retailer is
also reported to the authorities or
whichever governing body oversees
them lastly on the slide the public
assistance reporting information system
yes sir okay so I was listening to your
list of places where the ATMs may be you
know shut suspended or shut down from
the program um and they were all kind of
making sense to me uh until I heard you
talk about medicinal marijuana medicinal
marijuana is not considered a vice it's
a considered um you know me medicine so
uh what what is what would be the
distinct and maybe you can't answer this
now but I'd be interested in you know
John Williams or somebody explaining to
me what the legal distinction with be to
allow a lawful service to be shut down
based on what seems to me to be a
presumption of of
abuse so um you know the strip clubs and
the rest I'm you know that's that all
makes sense but the um medicinal pot is
different in New Hampshire I'd be happy
to look into that all right thank
you yeah
I do have one comment on that and that
is that medicinal marijuana is illegal
federally and um we're using federal
funds so um so even though it's a legal
activity uh within the state it's still
there's still some reach of the federal
government uh here in the program so you
sir are brilliant uh and it'll be
interesting to see if your answer gets
confirmed but yeah that's a good thought
thanks
any other questions
here so the uh Paris system um provides
data to States regarding recipients of
Public Assistance who are receiving
either duplicate benefits uh in two or
more States for the calendar year of
2023 there were four individuals in New
Hampshire on the New Hampshire Paris
report who were found to be in violation
of receiving duplicate tan of benefits
in two or more our
states we take action then uh regarding
those particular
individuals so have you completed your
list of other states and abuse yes okay
so let me let me tell you why that
question came up I we all have friends
and
family one of mine works for uh a
different State's um t
program and while we were you know
spending time together over the holidays
this is the kind of conversation my
family has so so don't you know it's not
too horrible but um if um he he alleged
that there's a tremendous amount of
fraud waste and abuse rampant in this
program around the country and he and
when he suggested that I you know hold a
hearing something like this
he said to really try to focus on that
because there are examples of States
having attempted to spend money in
inappropriate ways and it would just be
nice if we're able to identify those
guard rails a little bit better for the
future if we were able to do that that's
not urgent but it would be something
nice to know uh when we get our bite
back at the
Apple okay okay thank you slide
eight just at a high level these are the
key tanif eligibility criteria in New
Hampshire there's certainly more detail
behind this and I'm not going to go
through each one of these but just to
give you uh a sense of
that slide
nine Dives a little bit oh
sorry so regarding the group size
um what group is that referring to as a
group of one doesn't seem like it would
include a child unless it's only the
child what are we talking about there so
for example if that child has um both
parents um the child is not living with
either parent that child may be
considered as a group of
one so in that situation the child still
qualifies for Tan so going back to the
um f parent thing so you could have
foster parents where the child qualifies
is that no the the the child has to be
related
to the parent who would be receiving the
benefit by either blood marriage or
adoption and actually this past
legislative session we also added courta
appointed Guardians is qualifying for
the tanif grant basically for those
individuals who are taking in children
that they're not related to at all and
that number of parent or that number of
individuals is increasing in the state
so if they have been court appointed as
a guardian of a child they will now
qualify for the tanif program okay so go
back to the not not that case let's go
back to the family
case I'm try still trying to understand
how a child qualify as independent of
their blood related
parents because it may be a grandparent
for example who is applying for the
benefit on behalf of the
child and their income doesn't
necessarily count whereas the parents
would
correct okay thank
you slide nine digs in a bit for the
cash assistance grant this is the last
uh two and a half
years of that particular
Grant so the 29 million uh figure you
see at the bottom is the projected
expenditure of the grant for the end of
the state FIS schal
year Jess uh do you have a question go
ahead so there's a time limit of five
five 16 months what happens after that
point to the
family to the the recipient yes well to
the receipt of to them to the yeah
receipt of the
funding it it ends the 5 five years is
the term limit time limit forever for
that individual yes it's a fiveyear
lifetime limit so somebody may receive
tan of for like say a year uh then for
some reason their case closes then they
come back and reapply later so it's a
lifetime limit okay how many people age
out there a record of that uh we
probably do I can get that for you if
you want to know yeah be curious as to
what you know percentage Yeah we would
have um a record of how many um cases
Clos their tanif benefit because of a
child aging out
okay are child or family right not
necessarily just a
child or is this only to children I me
the family with the children yeah based
on the age of the
child based on age or number of
years so I think what you're asking is
if a parent is receiving the TANF
benefit then it goes to a grandparent so
the Money Follows the child I get that
but let's just take a straight family
with a a child and they're on
tan so they're a group of more than one
there may be a group of three let's say
mhm after five years that family is done
well one child may be then no longer
receiving that benefit but if there are
other children in the household
depending on when they particularly were
started into the benefit let's say the
second or third child wasn't born yet
okay so when we count group size are we
only counting
children in the group or are we counting
the parents no that that that's the the
household basically as long as they're
parents and children that's all you
count you don't count grandparents you
don't count correct okay yes yes okay I
know it's very
confusing slide 10 provide you with the
case count oh sorry over the last two
and a half
years go
ahead can you just clarify so we're
talking about a time limit of five years
is there a
um a monetary limit to the amount am I
reading this correctly that it's $5,000
or that so uh yeah the resource limit so
if they have resources assets basically
or access to resources the limit is
5,000 for uh individuals who are
receiving the benefit now for if you're
brand new and first applying for the
benefit that limit is
$1,000 so if you gained resources while
you were receiving TANF when you come up
for your
redetermination that resource limit then
changes to
5,000 okay thank
you so if you have a you have a child uh
that that qualifies is on the program
for two years parents leave the state
leave the child with the grandparents
they they apply again now it's the
grandparents and the one child now group
of one is that um is the clock start
over again or is that now third
year I believe that would be the third
year then for that child because it is
following the child not the adult
recipient okay thank
you may ask another questions but but
I'm going to follow up on that for you
okay one one question sort of related to
what I was thinking terms of a um a max
amount is there's a 5year time limit or
a counter let's say is there a max
amount of benefit that um a group can
receive a family can receive a child can
receive it's 60% of federal poverty
level depending on the household size
but it's 60% of that
level that is their
payment okay so there's not a specific
um point where they max out you 've
gotten the most amount of money we can't
give you any more you can't no because
it basically follows the time limit okay
and not a dollar limit thank
you uh just make sure I understand these
numbers here the 729 going up to 1500
that's based on what time period
monthly income that is yeah that is
monthly income thank
you
Jess yeah I'm I'm just a little thick
here so our group size as long as
there's one child and blood related
parents that it's the it's the count of
the children plus the blood related
parents that determines the group size
so Mom and Dad and two kids would get
would four be500
bucks well you wouldn't so we don't do
uh we haven't done the tanif um benefit
for two parent families uh in New
Hampshire we focus on the one parent
soly marri sorry yeah Minor Detail um
yeah so it's for one parent
um okay just to make sure okay we'll go
with one parent then so one parent three
children gets
$1,500
correct no parent so
grandparent three children gets
12:43 I will confirm that for you thank
you I I just want to make sure because
it is Trick some of the rules are really
tricky around tanif so let me just
confirm that for you
thanks all right so what I what I think
I just heard you say is that in New
Hampshire we've not had an experience
with a group that includes a child and
two
parents we've we've had apparently many
groups with a child and with a parent
but none with two parents and given that
it's one of the if I heard you wrong
then just tell me I'm wrong but but if I
heard you right and we go back to the
very beginning of one some of the
objectives of this program it's to
support two parent families and it just
makes me wonder if we're missing the
mark somehow if that's a stated
strategic objective but we don't have
any experience helping any of those
families if my memory serves correctly I
think we've did two parent households in
the past I think up until probably the
mid
2000s um but that program then we
stopped doing two parent families and
focused just on one I don't know why
that
was I'm sorry I couldn't hear
you so why did it stop I I don't know
that okay but I can find out okay I you
know I just think it's it's important in
the sense that so so many social
statistics indicate that children do
better in families that have two adults
helping take care of them in the
household so whether they're male female
whatever it doesn't much matter as long
as you got two committed adults trying
to raise a family that matters and so I
would just like to make sure that we're
not um underperforming because we're
failing to identify
one of the best things we can do to
improve the lives of our kids so so if
you could go back and check I will do
that thank
youc
particip
they well it it it's also supposed to
support um job training right so so so
you I think you've accurately quoted uh
an income but there's I think there's
more to this program if I'm learning
right but all right do you have anything
else
representative okay go
ahead so I am on slide
10 that provides you with the case count
over the last two and a half years and
you'll see that it's been as I said
earlier fairly steady
as far as those
cases okay so um my my accounting brain
wants to take this graph and be able to
break it down to the number of programs
that are being funded by these by this
cumulative line item so so like for
example at the outset of July we're just
short of 2800 case count it would be
nice to know if that 2800
represented 20 different programs that
get some funding or if this is all one
the same program this is just cash
assistance for the one tan of
program
okay and what percentage of that 70
million does this
represent
okay it it feels like a small
percentage it's a it's a big
percentage because this is this is
monthly it's not half but I think it's
37th whatever that is
so okay 42% something like
that if I read it
right um representative Edwards so cash
assistance is just some really quick
back of the envelope math here probably
about
40 40 some odd percent of of total tanif
expenditures thank thanks if later on if
you guys think that it's a different
number just let me know um no no it's
it's about 20 in uh State fiscal year 23
it was about $27 million total oh all
right thank you you're welcome you you
can continue without temporary
Interruption okay I'm going to move on
to slide 11 you asked me about audits
for the State uh So currently there is a
KPMG audit uh in progress for fiscal
year
23 and I have listed on this Slide the
findings from the the KPMG audit in
22 it's my understanding that none of
these are critical level findings uh and
I'm happy to describe
any a little bit more detail to any of
them if you're interested I'm going to
turn to representative wer who's our
resident audit expert any of these jump
out at you sir I haven't read any
these might be done internally might be
done internally but they don't come
before
fiscal so which is
unusual so I I know there's a lot of
audits you do within the department
we don't see them
all I guess they're available yes maybe
we'll ask for more of them at at budget
time or maybe we ask Kevin to put them
on the we the LBA
website where the audits are I'm not
sure these would necessarily be LBA
conducted audits that we're talking
about I think internal to the department
y I understand that you can you not post
them for us um I can look into that we
just generally only post our own audits
online though um but I can I can see
what we can do okay or are they
available on your
website I don't think we post them
either but I can certainly make
information available to
you I I think I might have just learned
something else which is I I had assumed
that
all thirdparty audits that come into the
state have to go sort of through the uh
checkin of our audit team that the our
audit team is supposed to at least be
aware and a recipient of the results
that there that we don't have
independent audits at the state level do
we or well we have we have a a busy
audit team and there's about 30 people
but they they have a cycle where they do
almost every Department every five years
and performance audits has requested and
the number of audits it would take in
the Department of Health and Human
Services 20% of their work basically is
done with contractors I suppose they
have a method to um audit those
contractors but it doesn't come through
our audit division it goes through their
own internal so we would have to request
to see those um and it' probably be a
good idea at at uh budget time to be
asking for them all up front but you
might see a pile like that
right we have several weeks before we
actually ever get
the the governor's budget though
so all right we would see at this
session I I think we're on slide
12 very
well so current trends in the TANF
program you had asked about so from
first from a federal perspective the
federal government is committed to
ensuring that states are accountable for
meeting tanif requirements so re a
review of State spending patterns has
led them to consider legislative or
regulatory remedies to ensure that
states are not using any flexibilities
to avoid tanif requirements or otherwise
undermine the statutory goals of the
program State programs have shifted away
from the focus on Direct Cash and
employment assistance although states
are permitted under the statute to
determine how much funding to expend on
cash
assistance the administration for
children and family families reminds us
that there is a large body of research
that shows cash assistance is a
critically important tool for reducing
Family and Child poverty and recipients
are less likely to be involved in the
child welfare
system despite the evidence that it
reduces child and family poverty cash
assistance in 2020 this is on a national
level accounted for less than 23% of tan
of funds compared to 71% in
1997 the federal government also
believes that states are under investing
in work Education and Training for
parents with low incomes as well as
critical work
supports as a result the office of
family assistance has taken actions to
in the form of a uh pending notice of
proposed rul making there's seven
components to that proposed rule uh I
will just mention the the the first
three of them one to establish a ceiling
on the term needy so that it may not
exceed a family income of 200% of
federal federal poverty
guidelines in 2024 the federal poverty
level at 200% for an individual ual is
$29,100
for family of four it's 60,000 660,000
which is not very
much determining when an expenditure is
reasonably calculated to accomplish a
tan of purpose is another uh uh section
of the proposed
Rule and third they are proposing to
exclude third-party non-governmental
spending as allowable maintenance of
effort can I ask a question go ahead
regarding your statement about States
underinvestigated on
that I what I would like to do is wait
for the national proposed rule making to
see or the the proposed rule making just
to see what that comes out looking like
if we're looking at um the F federal
poverty level of uh 200% for
families I we can definitely look at our
own rule which we currently set at 60%
of federal poverty level
I me I guess I could ask a question a
different way this analysis which the
federal government did must have had
some metrics for determining the states
overall were
underinvestigated
okay thank you
so this is really late in the game for
me to mention this but I
assume Mr White that you're keeping
track of the questions and we're going
to get answers back yes we're keeping
track all right it's just been a while
since we've done this
so I'm taking
notes so using the Tana of funds um New
Hampshire is is well invested uh in
employment supports for tanif
recipients the department administers
the New Hampshire employment program
also known as
NH which is a work program specifically
for low-income families with children
the goal of this program is to end
dependency on public assistance by
promoting job preparation and
employment the NH career counselors
provide services on Workforce
Development education case management
and reduction in barriers to employment
and to prepare participants for industry
specific career lad
employment nhp focuses on closing the
skills Gap or
upskilling individuals by ensuring job
Seekers gain and increase their
competencies earning credentials that
businesses require for employment and
enhancing people's eligibility for
higher wage position
positions nhp aims to build a skilled
pipeline of qualified employees to meet
the needs of businesses in New Hampshire
while fostering self-confidence and
preparing participants to be valued
employees DHHS also works closely with
Partners uh with the workforce
Innovation board including Department of
business business and economic Affairs
department of education employment
security and the New Hampshire College
Community College
system the workforce Innovation and
Opportunity Act also known as
weoa uh the local Services uh provider
for Statewide Services which is our
community action uh Association our cap
programs operate under the guidance of
anou to maintain the New Hampshire Works
onstop delivery system in other words we
all work together to serve individuals
and Families is including tanif
recipients to reach self-sufficiency and
economic stability through
employment Tana funds are also
supporting New Hampshire Cliff effect
initiatives in
2021 there was published a pretty
comprehensive economic analysis study uh
that basically gave us recommendations
of ways the state could look at
mitigating the cliff effect
one of those initiatives which we have
implemented is a pilot program a
two-year pilot program that provides for
an optional
75% income disregard for any tan of
participants who starts new new
full-time employment or seeks a
promotion to their
employment for those employed in high
demand jobs that are identified by
Employment Security we've implemented a
100% income disrup regard for those who
enter new employment or take a
promotion the pilot program began in
October of 22 and it lasts through
September of
24 the intent is to incentivize more
households to work and increase their
earnings and
Savings in the last legislative session
we were uh provided with authority and
some funding to continue that particular
economic study and and that is ongoing
now at this time with the intent to look
at uh further uh mitigation strategies
for the cliff effect but also to
consider graduated assistance programs
for the
state I am expecting that we'll be able
to report back to the legislature this
spring on the outcomes of that
report do you know who you might be
reporting that to HHS oversight or
somebody mhm okay yes thank
you tanif is also supporting the kinship
navigation program that I mentioned
earlier these are Services focused on
providing resource and economic
connections to support kinship care
families there are currently
1,70 individuals receiving Services
through
kinship it also supports the
comprehensive Family Support Services
Program which is a community- based home
visiting program serving New Hampshire
family
Statewide uh who are either pregnant or
have children ages 0 to
21 this is designed to provide
preventative Services so here's where
you had asked me earlier about the focus
on two three and four in the tan of
purposes so they provide services such
as household management budgeting
techniques positive parenting techniques
Child Development screenings case
management and resource and referral
services are based on fam's individual
needs uh as identified in an individual
support plan currently there are
1,188 families receiving this particular
service which accounts for 82 and 82% of
them are tanif
eligible in the 2425 banian budget hb2
authorized the department to utilize tan
of funds to cover any shortfall for
specific Child Care eligibility and
provider rate
changes M
question do you have to know what
section that was in h did you say that
was this year 2023 hb2 M yes you know
what section it
is yes I do I can I can find that for
you you so I
don't
okay there are like three or four any
restrictions on recent
immigrants what was that word recent
immigrants in other words if if
uh someone can move here from overseas
and immediately go on this
assistance so that would be the uh
likely the refugee
assistance program um I can get you more
information specifically the policy on
that program in New
Hampshire because it
the federal U Ser service seems to be oh
you've haven't spent all your money on
on needy families will'll send you more
from Mexico or wherever they come in
from um that's what's happening in some
of these
states
I'll move to slide
13 so New Hampshire's focus on the
future really our duty to align the
department policy and our it systems
with the fiscal responsibility Act of
2023 that is one Focus for New Hampshire
it includes changes to what data states
can use for the work participation rate
uh provides for new mandated reports and
it gives us an opportunity to
participate in a six-year pilot program
to look at different Statewide
performance metrics in lie of the work
participation rate work participation
rate really doesn't tell us about
outcomes for families so we want to take
a look at what other metrics may be
available and worthwhile for collecting
data that's what the federal government
is interested in
yes so uh Meredith Tellus I think is her
last name is is uh I know that she's
very busy small staff focused primarily
on contract metrics performance metrics
is is she sharing any bandwidth with you
to to take a look at uh any benchmarks
that that you all may have in the for
the future programs we would likely
engage with her and her team if we are
selected for that particular pilot there
are only five states that will be
selected uh the application process
hasn't started yet but we intend to
apply all right thank
you uh another focus is known as the
whole family's approach to jobs
initiative uh this was launched in 2017
led by the administration for Children
and Families it began as a New England
initiative focused on bringing together
a broad range of stakeholders ERS to
create lasting change to our state
programs and policies placing families
at the center and offering a connection
to Regional and and federal Partners uh
to address intergenerational poverty and
contribute to the state's economic
growth and
prosperity in the 2023 legislative
session I mentioned how the department
was authorized to continue that 202
economic analysis regarding the cliff
effect and conduct a study of graduated
assistance programs for New Hampshire so
that is one of our
focuses and if you will I would like to
close by sharing some words from two
different tanif recipients very
briefly tanif income I received has
helped my family tremendously this month
I was able to pay my electric off so I
have a zero balance at this time which I
don't think I I've ever been completely
abled or caught up with my electric I
also was able to pay my car payment and
insurance on time I have not had to
reach out for resources to help with
food like I usually do at the end of the
month even with a class picnic and two
field trips that required packed lunches
my son was in need of new shoes as he
had been wearing the same pair since
before school had started 12-year-old
boys aren't gentle with anything I was
able to buy a new pair with money I had
put aside for emergencies and it felt
good to be able to provide him provide
him with them in hopes that they last a
little bit longer this time those are
just a few examples of how the tan of
income has helped my
family a work participant in the nhp
program says that this has been a
lifechanging uh event for her she notes
that transitioning into a new job and
now having money come in has made her
life easier she notes that she's been
been able to support her children and
actually have money she notes this
program made the transition into working
easier it also allowed her to view and
change her spending habits she notes
that she was a pretty heavy smoker and
quit before beginning this
career with having less stress over
finances she chose to do that and this
has made a significant difference in her
budgeting she feels that this would not
have happened without this program the
program has allowed her to not have to
worry and know that she can afford an
emergency thank
you could you talk a little bit about
housing and I mean you look at the the
incomes that what we're allowing people
to have um and this none of these would
be able to um be able to afford an
apartment in conquered so how do we keep
these families housed uh with these
small um very small I benefits that
we're paying them sure and I'm not sure
I can answer the question directly but I
can certainly provide other information
I can go back and get you some other
information we do work with the Bureau
of housing or Bureau of homeless
Services it changed last year the name
of it and focus of it is really on
homelessness um but we also work very
closely with the New Hampshire uh house
Finance Authority uh to address some of
these issues which is all a part of that
whole fam's for jobs uh approach to jobs
rather um so there's there's a lot of
collaboration that is going on because
we're really looking at not just housing
but child care as you know is uh
certainly a very expensive um uh cost
for families in New Hampshire so we're
trying to do things like promote the
child care scholarship making changes
through of um the eligibility for child
care uh but really combining it all
needs to to we all need to work
collaboratively in trying to address the
programs there is no single solution to
to all of it or we likely would have
solved it by
now thank
you that's a question um when we talk
about the job training and we all know
the workforce challenges we have in the
state can you give me an example of um
how the program could work with that is
it more like a could it be a a grant or
a scholarship grant for someone to
attend a certificate program at a
community college or something like that
can you just give us some examples sure
so we have a degree of uh funds within
the budget to uh use for some expenses
uh that people may incur as a result of
searching for or obtaining work it could
be costs for mileage to do job searching
it could be costs for like a uniform in
a particular
employer uh that the individual wouldn't
have the funding for otherwise to be
able to go uh do that job we also cover
things like automobile uh repairs like
one time repair for uh you know to fix
an automobile so you can get to work um
it can also cover um uh it can cover
child care as well so we're talking
about real Basics like I got a job and I
need to wear black pants and a black
shirt every single day yes that's what
we're talking about we're not talking
about a few thousand dollars to go to
Nashville Community College for a
certificate program correct okay thank
you for nin job
someone or a waitress
job any other questions over there
representative for
it um just a couple of follow-up
questions on um on the 60-month
restriction and I think you said
eligibility is 60% in the state of New
Hampshire of the federal poverty limit
um I want to make sure I understand so's
right but those restrictions are things
put put on by you know essentially us
the state legislature the federal limits
could be higher is that true or or am I
misunderstanding I thought I heard you
say at least in the proposed rule the
federal limitation would be 200% of the
federal po poverty limit but I also
heard 60% regards to the state so the
federal government sets the requirement
for the time limit 16 months so that is
set by by the federal government uh but
the payment that we issue there are
there is some flexibility that we can
determine what that criteria
is so right now I can tell you that
we're working with the other New England
states to really identify and do a bit
of a comparison if you will as far as
what criteria um or what uh what
programs are providing for cash
assistance so in New Hampshire it
happens to be right now 60% federal
poverty
level okay and is that is that something
that you look for the legislature for
guidance on or is that something that's
done by the department that would be set
by our own administrative rules okay
thanks um
Minister you you it sounded like you
were saying that Financial expenditures
may be set by an administrative rule I
don't know if I understood you properly
the the level of the payment that is
issued to cash re assistance recipients
is set by administrative Rule and that
must be following a
statute uh yes we have the authority for
R
making just making
sure
um um two things that could help one is
um you know um one is a maybe a pie
chart you know showing the tan of funds
I think we said 42% of them roughly are
are going into the cash portion uh I
think some of it is
Administration maybe just a pie chart
shown where the rest is if there's
anything else that comes out and if you
could provide a link to the Federal
Register notice on the on the tanif rule
that you were discussing appreciate it I
can do that
thanks so
I had to harp on this family thing and
all that but going back to that and
understanding now that it's the child
that matters here do you have metrics on
how many let's just say children uh are
able to get out of this program thanks
to the help this program
provides obviously I understand it means
the family situation has to get out of
it um before the fiveyear uh time frame
and when you get to the we'd ask about
the metrics of how many people time out
how many of them after they time out are
have gained enough from the program that
they would no longer qualify for the
program despite the fact that their
fiveyear timeout has
lapsed so I can certainly provide
information about the reasons for
closure of the tanif program by any
particular family so we do track the
reasons why they would no longer be
receiving tanif be it they became over
income uh aged out MET the time limit
there's I'm sure several other reasons
so I can certainly provide that for any
given period of
time we don't track families after their
tanif is closed I understand that I just
like to know how successful the programs
are I mean are you actually are we
moving people into a situation or at
least at a point in time they appear to
right no longer qualify because theyve
the program's been successful and moving
them into jobs and getting them Health
uh childcare and so on one of the things
that we are initiating uh in uh a
contract is it's a current RFP um that
uh we are going through that particular
procurement process for includes what's
what we're calling a post tanif Support
Program um so the intent to that is to
really work with families once their tan
of closes to make sure that they have
the support they need moving forward to
continue moving forward and not back on
tanif if they would still be
eligible
great looking on page eight at resource
limit ,000 for applicants so if you own
a car that works and it can be
registered you probably have more than
,000 worth of
resources
I think what I'll do is get you the
definition of
resources you're
welcome okay um so I don't really have
any more questions I I want to make sure
that everyone on the committee has had
an opportunity to ask anything that they
want and this has meant to just be an
educational form uh I think uh I learned
Maybe 40% of what you were able to
present today so that wasn't a very good
silk rate but I do appreciate your
patience um as as I as I well before I
leave it um do you have any comments for
this approach I mean we've not I I don't
know that division 3 has done this
before U just bring you in for an
educational session would you recommend
this to for other divisions or has this
been a
kind of a huge consumption of your time
without much payoff I would say that
it's a well-invested use of time I think
anytime we have the opportunity to meet
face to face in this manner and provide
you with information that helps you in
making any particular decisions that is
time well worth spent okay how about you
Mr White because you you're so busy
doing
everything no I I I think this is a
great use of time I I think um you know
when we as as everybody on this
committee well knows once we get going
in the budget we have 52,000 decisions
to make and learning about the
intricacies of a new program is is not
um sometimes the the highest priority so
I think this is certainly helpful so if
I come back here in a year and I'm I'm
pleading and begging for additional
money for the TANF Moe everyone on this
committee will know what that represents
so I I I think it could certainly be
helpful so thank you we appreciate the
opportunity okay thank you I could I ask
one more question go ahead so you seem
to have
notes beyond the slides that you were
speaking from I do is it possible to get
those sure be great because there's a
lot of things you said that I couldn't
record quickly enough that I think would
help to fill in for the slides I'd be
happy to it was a lot of detail there
thank
you okay so um the the a piece of this
that I know that I don't know enough but
from what I know it doesn't sound like
the state is doing everything it really
ought to be doing leveraging tanif to do
back on page two bullets two and four
specifically related to um end
dependence of needy parents on
government benefits by promoting
marriage I I I don't I'm back led by
that I don't even know what that would
look like but uh that would be an
interesting U brainstorming session
someday may be amongst experts so I I'll
just say that that's the work we're
currently doing on the whole family
approach to jobs initiative working with
our six all the six New England states
yeah to really look at a comparison but
we're also taking that to the next level
and looking at what other states Beyond
New England are doing in this space uh
and to be able to see how successful
they were what metrics are they
collecting um what were some of the
factors influencing those particular
initiatives so there's a lot of work
that to be done but it takes certainly a
thorough process in vetting what it is
that those other initiatives may be um
and that certainly takes some time and
our own resources to be able to do that
sure and thanks for tri because I I had
another question there for you um but uh
since I just mentioned two I'd also
mention four you know maintenance of two
parent families I I um having seen them
up close uh I know it doesn't matter
what the genders of the parents are as
long as somebody's there to support the
child and somebody's there to support
the primary parent uh that's a very
healthy stable environment and kids
thrive in that environment so so
whatever we can do I think it really has
a force multiplicate
multip anyways Force multiplier on the
impact of our state Investments if we
can encourage more stable families to
raise their children the um other
question you triggered was um um could
you just off the top of your head give
us an approximate of how many people um
you work for you in your department and
how you're doing with um having your
Manpower
filled sure so for the program that
oversees uh tanif eligibility so I have
uh five different areas that I overy uh
so in this particular one through the
Bureau of family assistance there are uh
off the top of my head I think it's
200 like 70 full-time employees uh we
have a current current vacancy rate of
uh it's been steady at like
22% uh for the eligibility
field oh now at
19.8% okay so filled positions total
positions is
393 so what's what's the major pain
point of you being at um only 78% of
your
Staffing I would say uh just the
difficulty in recruiting for this
position it's a very low paid uh
positions for the work that they do
having to be experts in over 40
different eligibility programs um I
think that it's
uh difficult to recruit for that
particular position we've uh submitted
last year a request for reclassification
or I'm sorry actually a re um um
allocation is that the right word
um basically to try to move them into a
higher pay band and I'm still waiting
for the division of personnel to make a
decision on that so I didn't ask the
question right by paino I mean what
damage is being done to your ability to
execute the mission as opposed to you
know the the problems you're having with
getting the people filled I think that
it's taxing on the quality of service
that we try to provide I hear frequently
about difficulties in reaching uh staff
to resolve uh and address issues that
are important to clients as well as
other stakeholders such as our providers
for
Medicaid um so it's it's definitely
something that without the proper level
of resources that we find um uh
bottlenecks in some of those processes
because we just don't have enough people
to act on everything as quickly as we'd
like
to go ahead representative so does that
translate there's families who have come
forward looking for assistance and
they're just is not the staff to help
them and they're it's being they're
being delayed in their receiving help
right I'd like to say that we help every
single one of them I'm sure you do but
uh definitely I think we I it's safe to
say that we experiened delays in in
either returning phone calls or
processing documents there are several
bottlenecks uh as a result of the lack
of appropriate resources so that is you
know potentially harmful to
people all right
um that that's everything I had I I
really appreciate your time um and your
education so so for the committee if we
could just stick around another three
minutes um I'd appreciate it thank thank
you thank you very much for your
interest I have a list of things to
follow up on and it may take me a bit of
time to do that but I will get that for
you out outstanding thanks okay so so
this was an experiment um uh I I maybe
it's too early for you to have an
impression of whether or not this was
worth your time we have a few more weeks
here where we uh where we are not
looking at a bill um divisions one and
two are but we or not so we have
some you could call it spare time um one
of the things that I've been wanting to
do for years now but the pandemic got in
the way so I I was thinking about going
and visiting some of the uh inst
institutions that we have that we fund
that we've never gotten to uh so that's
an idea um also as I was talking to
representative walner the other day she
mentioned that uh she might appreciate
something like this in the long-term
care area um and so uh I'm open to those
kinds of ideas I would just ask you if
you have a topic like long-term care
that you help me by developing you know
a a bullet list of of what the agenda
might look like so that they have time
to prepare we have time to prepare you
know that sort of thing not not required
but it would be helpful um so with that
I'll just open it up and say what do he
what do you respond I mean we have the
option of doing nothing and just waiting
for second committee or we have the
option of doing something and then if
we're going to do something we can
figure out if we' maybe want to go take
one of these uh site visits or if we
want to bring in another special topic
I'm I'm I'm open to your
thoughts
I think the idea of a site visit is
going be interesting to know how many of
all of all of us that are here have
visited New Hampshire hospital for
instance I haven't visited any of the
facilities I I didn't think you had
because I've only visited the
veterans uh um Clinic what I've been to
veterans home we could do that um it's
not as exciting as something I've not
seen
yet I'm kidding of course but I I I I'll
tell you what why don't we just um if
you want to do a site visit just email
me saying hey here's what I here's where
I'd like to site visit and then I'll
just count them up and figure out if
there's a natural priority
there wait from today we'll have a full
committe
okay if Mary Jane was asking about New
Hampshire hospital I've not visited
there just to answer her question I have
not visited New Hampshire hospital which
I think was what Mary Jan was asking we
we actually tried a couple years ago but
the pandemic got in the way so that's
that's still on the table it was a good
tour and then also given the
construction that they're trying to do
there it there's even more reason to go
there so I I I like that and the ranging
Transportation there gets to be pretty
convenient so but U just so I'm going to
take New Hampshire hospital as a yes and
if there's a second one I'll wait for
people to suggest it all right and then
how how should I go about arranging a a
tour there Mr Ripple you go through
Janet do what um yeah either Janet or I
can try to set it up I don't know if
there's a day or time that would work
best for everybody but I can find out
what's available and then let you know
the
options okay let me let me ask the chair
a trivia question
um what the what days are the division
one and two meeting in
general I know you like us to meet on
Thursdays don't you well what's
happening is that um the health and
human service committee wants to use
this committee room Wednesdays and
Thursdays and they've got a bunch of
bills they want to get out of the way
and I said yes we'll probably make the
room available because we won't have
that many meetings so after crossover
yeah we'll be loaded so so that actually
works out because we're looking for a
day to go to the New Hampshire hospital
and a and a Wednesday sounds like a good
day because there's already competition
for this room right so I I'm going to
propose that we look for the next next
available Wednesday where we don't see a
conflict okay all right well with that
Mr Ripple any final words of wisdom nope
I have nothing Mr
chair next Monday for a full committee
meeting at 10 o'clock and uh I think
division two is going to have a meeting
that afternoon a vision one I believe is
already finished with the bills they had
but after we have the full committee
some of the divisions will be having for
the meetings on the bills that we will
have have met with for the full
committee okay um and I assume you're in
touch with the representative nordgren I
hope she's
okay I don't I don't know anything about
representative hle is anyone he from him
how's he doing hasn't been not has not
been in touch all right okay well thanks
we're
adjourned all
right